hi Jake what's going on living your best
life huh yeah like in a windowless hotel
room wonderful yeah yeah smell what a
fight
oh really Oh what do you think what did
you think I was violent last night oh
yeah I wasn't well hmm a little bit like
I had it like a can you do a slight
Wilin yeah I don't know if you can yeah
you can do it
I mean you slightly wild I don't know
about that slightly Wilin oh that
actually put that's like that sums me up
and like two words I yeah I know I went
to go see David Blaine's show did yeah
yeah yeah look at you yeah doing stuff
he was violent I was sitting there
watching him he's crazy yeah really good
though I think that's too simple of a
word to describe him mmm-hmm okay so
let's talk about through either on Ellen
okay you said that the sexiest avenger
yes originally was Thomas spider-man and
then you switched it to Thor yeah and I
think Tom feels away about it I think we
should talk about it did you talk to him
first you gonna talk to her I talked to
Eddie how he did mm-hmm
what I felt like was let me be honest
I'm I'm a performer and when I said it
there wasn't quite the same response as
when I said Thor if I'm honest and I was
surprised because you you heard my truth
yes at first yeah but then I felt like I
had to appease the audience and um I
mean it's like the easy go-to isn't it
yeah okay I know I mean you can't beat
me uh I mean what who's your favorite I
I can't play that game with me why I
don't play these oh right now pressures
on and you're gonna take you oh we're
not doing it okay happening okay
let's talk about your suit yeah Mysterio
suit uh-huh
did you hate it or love it was it
uncomfortable to give you like
confidence that you didn't have before
let's talk about it I like all the above
I mean I I really love the suit I mean I
like I didn't like to take the suit off
really yeah I mean it was a
it's very hot suit it like has a number
of layers to it so it um took a little
bit time to put on but once it was on
yeah it made me feel pretty strong
though I had like a 40-pound cape
attached to my neck as a cape yeah but
um I was a little worried about the suit
before we did it
you know I before I put it on her before
I saw it cuz he has a fishbowl yeah
helmet I didn't know how that was gonna
play but they killed it with the
fishbowl helmet so it worked
yeah it worked have you been offered to
play a superhero or a villain in the
past uh yeah yeah turn it down no no I
mean I have I have been in disc I mean
like you know the cool thing about these
movies is that if you're an actor and
you're trying to act you're trying to
get a role whatever it might be
throughout the years I've been working
for 25 years now in movies you know
you're up for different roles you're in
discussion for different roles you're
auditioning for different roles
throughout your entire career because
these movies I mean at least in my
career in the span of what I've done
there have been three franchises of the
spider-man movies you know made and so
inevitably those conversations come on
yeah okay well I'm happy you got to do
this music
you